- I have succeeded because I had to.
Well, I have made a lot of great products,
but there's also been some real duds.
That's what successful
business is all about,
spotting new opportunities
and exploiting them.
I have to be half-dead
not to not go to work.
I got a philosophy, which
is stick to what you know.
Generally, people that stay with you
are motivated not
necessarily just by money,
but they're motivated by the enjoyment.
Answer emails immediately,
answer people's questions immediately.
That's been my success.
I would not take on something
that I couldn't see a light
at the end of the tunnel.
Because if you engross yourself too much
in the day to day running of the business,
you might find that the
world is passing you by.
I can only talk from my experience.
My products did the talking.
- He's an English business
magnate, political advisor,
and television personality.
In 2007, he sold his remaining interest
in his Amstrad company, which
was his most well-known,
and most successful business venture.
He has an estimate fortune
of 1.4 billion pounds.
He's Alan Michael Sugar,
and here are his Top 10 Rules for Success.
(whooshing)
(booming)
- I don't wish to alienate people here
with about what I'm about to say.
But you know, your
destiny is in your hands.
I have succeeded because I had to.
No one sorted anything out for me.
I didn't ask, go to any
government and said,
pretty please, find me some work,
please, and do something for me,
because it was a waste of bloody time.
Simply that, a waste of time.
And if I was going to do
something, I had to do it myself.
And that's it, and I would
say to every one of you here,
don't sit around relying upon, magically,
some government going
to create an environment
that's going to make it easy for you
to find work and find jobs.
You've got to go out there
and fight for it yourself.
I'm sorry to say, I
can't give you any other,
any other form of advice.
If you want something
bad enough, you do it.
And if you look at some of these wannabes
have made themselves television stars
and pop stars and all that type of stuff,
they have a desire to want to be famous,
and they don't stop until
they're recognized and they do.
And half the people that you
see on television these days
in the entertainments industry are those
that had the determination
that wanted to do it.
And I'll add a little rider to that,
none of them could bloody sing.
(audience laughing)
Not helpful, right, I mean,
you didn't find that helpful answer.
But you're going to control
your destiny, I'm telling you.
No one else is going to do it.
Not unless you got a rich dad.
(audience laughing)
Have you got a rich dad, a rich uncle?
No, well then, that's it.
You're going to have to do it yourself.
And then you have to be realistic
also, and not a dreamer.
And that's one thing people
said about me after the event.
I talk as if I've always
made great products.
Well, I have made a lot of great products,
but there's also been some real duds.
And one of the things about me is,
is that as much as I, as well
as I know the marketplace,
and know if I got a hit on my hand,
I also know when I've got a dud on my hand
and know to cut, wipe your face, get out,
and clear it out and get rid of it,
don't waste any more time, move on.
And I think a lot of
people are not prepared
to recognize that
something's been a failure.
And you're successful
by, on many occasions,
by learning mistakes,
from your failures also.
A successful business person needs to
exploit the market or the
sector that they are in.
They need to have a great
understanding of it.
They need to constantly
monitor the marketplace
and spot opportunities.
That's what successful
business is all about,
spotting new opportunities
and exploiting them.
Most success stories in
expansion of businesses
are based upon enhancements
learnt from the core business
that you're already in.
Adding additional features to products,
expanding product ranges,
ideas that come from what
you're already doing,
particularly in manufacturing.
Your own employees could actually come up
with some spark of genius
in streamlining the production process,
something that you may have
never thought about before,
something that could save
you lots and lots of money.
Or suddenly come up
with an idea based upon
the product that you're
producing that is allied to it.
When you come from
the working class
background that I come from,
I feel guilty
at 10 to five, if I'm not in the office.
I know that might sound strange to you,
but there's a work ethic
that I have to be half-dead
not to not go to work.
It's kind of a work ethic
that's built into me, you know?
But nevertheless, having said all that,
the weekends, that was it, it's over,
switch off like a light Friday night
as you got back from the
office or from the work
or from the factory, whatever.
No matter what was
buzzing around in my head,
it was off like a light
switch, and that's it.
Don't let it interfere,
very rarely let it
interfere with the weekend.
And then Monday morning,
bang, back on it again,
as if you flicked the switch on again.
So I think was a bit of
discipline in that respect.
I got a philosophy, which
is stick to what you know.
And real estate, as I
explained in detail already,
is something that I know now
and of course, electronics
is something that I know,
and the answer, very simply, is no,
I wouldn't invest in a business
that I didn't understand.
I would invest in
businesses that I understood
but didn't necessarily want to run them.
And I think that's a good philosophy also,
is to stick to what you know.
But generally, people that stay with you
are motivated not
necessarily just by money,
but they're motivated by the enjoyment
or the excitement of what you're creating
and the fact that you
make them part of a team.
And that they can see that
they're actually achieving something
towards the goal of the organization.
And I think if you ostracize people
or you don't show them your
appreciation in that way,
then you can expect them
not to show that loyalty.
- When you've gone from
looking out of windows
at classrooms,
to having a very regimented
timetable on the weekends,
how did you develop such
a good self-discipline?
- I don't know, I am very disciplined.
That's all I could say to
you, very, very, disciplined,
a creature of habit.
What's that thing, is it called
OCD, or something like that.
If you look at my desk, you'll
see all the pens lined up,
like that, and the piece
of paper over here,
and a cup over there and all that.
I'm just very disciplined, that's it.
I think in business and in life,
I work on the principle
of clearing my desk
every minute, or every day.
So answer emails immediately,
answer people's questions immediately.
That's been my success
in running my company,
that I'm there to, like a
springboard, if you like,
for employees to tell
me what their issue is
and then to give them a quick resolution
to it so they can get on and deal with it.
So that's my discipline.
I would heartily recommend
it to all of you.
If you decide to become,
you should be disciplined,
you should discipline yourself.
Because it's not a bad way of life.
We've been through an era
of massive bankruptcies
or liquidations and receiverships,
particularly in the property world
where lots of money has
been lent against assets
which were over-valued, for example.
I, fortunately, didn't
play in that market.
My son's in this business with me,
and we kind of sat around
watching what was going on,
and knowing that this is a forced-market.
I would not take on something
that I couldn't pay for,
myself, I would not take on something
that I couldn't see a light
at the end of the tunnel,
where we come out of it.
And I know that's pretty
much stating the obvious,
and it doesn't apply to all businesses,
but I think it's a good philosophy.
That's to always have a
kind of a wake up call,
whether it be weekly,
monthly, or six-monthly,
where you are, where you're
going, what you're doing.
And it's easier in some businesses,
because you know, it's blatantly obvious
where you're going in some businesses,
because if it's a retail business,
it's, have you got customers
coming across the table
or the counter for naught?
In other businesses, particularly
like service businesses,
where there is no product
that you touch and feel,
and that your income comes from
being an agent, for example,
you have to constantly
look at your overheads and your costs.
And I think that it is cost-control,
regular wake up calls,
regular checks of where you are,
status checks of where you
are, will keep you afloat.
You need to set aside a day per week,
where you divorce yourself from
the day to day activity of your company.
You must have someone inside
the company who you trust.
God forbid, you ever got run
over by a Number Six bus,
think of that person who
would have to take control
and put that person in
control for that day,
or for those two days.
And then use those two days
to go out into the marketplace
to find yourself some new business
or at least observe what your
competitors are getting up to
and what they're doing
in order to see how
the market is changing.
Because if you engross yourself too much
in the day to day running of the business,
you might find that the
world is passing you by
and you're missing opportunities.
Well, I think that you could be,
I mean, the point is, is that there's
the integrity and honesty,
as far as I'm concerned
goes without saying,
and you can push that to
one side at the moment.
Because you can be honest
and have a high integrity,
but if you've got lousy product,
or prices are too high, it's irrelevant.
So it's a mixture of
spotting opportunities,
I mean, target from the
top of your own business,
spotting opportunities,
products, services,
that you want to offer that do bring value
to whomever you're going to sell them to,
and then having the nous
to go and sell them.
I mean, again, this young
man's question over there,
it's very, very similar.
I get asked a lot a similar
question in universities
and places like this.
You don't just jump out
of bed one Monday morning
and I want to be Richard Branson,
I'm going to start an airline.
Like that, I want to start
an airline tomorrow morning.
Total nonsense, have you got any money?
No, but I want to start an
airline tomorrow morning.
And so there's a certain realism
as to what one month needs to do.
Secondly, you've got to look at,
you got to also have a
realistic point of view.
I'm new, I'm starting,
I've got a new business.
What do I offer somebody?
What do I offer my potential customer?
What have I got that
they can't already get
from 20 or 30 or 40 or 50 other people?
Because if I'm not offering
anything different,
then I've got a tough job ahead of me.
And I think you have to continually
test yourself on that basis.
I used to test myself with products.
Is this a good product or not?
Well, has anybody else got one?
Or is it the same as what
other people have got
but half the price, does it do more,
has it got different features
on it, is it look better,
is the market ready for it?
That's the test and from my point of view,
I can only talk from my experience,
my products did the talking.
You know, I could be the
greatest salesman in the world,
the most charming person in the world,
whatever you want to be,
and you could advertise
and do whatever you want.
If the product sucks,
then you got no business.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed the video.
I made it because Iain
Fairley asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below,
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of Alan Sugar's top 10
rules meant the most to you.
Leave it in the comments,
I'll join in the discussion.
Thank you so much for
watching, continue to believe,
and I'll see you soon.
(whooshing)
(booming)
- [Man] Do you think
source like Apprentice
have genuinely a positive
impact on entrepreneurship?
- You mean, the program?
- [Man] Yeah.
- Okay, okay.
- [Man] Because your program
is immensely successful.
I love it.
(audience laughing)
We all watch it, but we
haven't seen big success--
- Okay, I think I get what
you're saying, but look.
(audience laughing)
I feel like I'm in the
boardroom, a candor bit there.
No no, I think I know
where you're coming from.
The thing is, is that you
might, you like the program.
And I guess that you like it because
you think it's entertaining and
you like looking at somebody
you might think is a right numpty,
and that's why you like it.
What you don't realize in
the back of your mind is,
is that you are picking up
some of the business message
that is there, okay?
Now there was, well, you might
not admit it, but you are.
And I can tell you that
from when I started doing
this Apprentice thing,
the amount of young people that
are inspired by the program,
put aside all the fun and the laughter
and all the clowns that you
think you've come across.
The amount of people
that are inspired by it,
the amount of people that were,
they put to me their business ideas.
And I think it does, it performs a very,
very good service amongst the
young, to be honest with you.
And you can't get a
better endorsement of it
when it becomes part of the curriculum
at some schools where they set up a mini,
a mini kind of apprentice task.
And the amount of times
that I've been asked
to attend schools to try and judge this.
I just couldn't do them,
there's enough time in the day.
So yes, it does inspire people.
It entertains, and it inspires.
- Who inspires you, and why?
- Well, I don't...
I wouldn't say that where I've got today
is because I was inspired
by others, I think...
The thing is, I often say to people that,
you know, you're born
with a certain thing here.
You know, this kind of gut feeling,
this kind of determination,
you're born with it.
I try to make the analogy of that,
some people are born with a talent.
If you locked me a room
with a piano teacher,
for example, for one year,
no doubt at the end, I
could perhaps knock out
a rendition of Roll Out the Barrel, maybe.
Would I ever be a concert pianist?
Not in a million years.
Because in that example,
that person has a talent.
And I think I was blessed
with some kind of talent
of some kind, you see,
which, an eye for things,
a very fast brain to
see the end conclusion.
Normally, the end conclusion,
I'm very skeptical
of what can go wrong,
and that is something,
I'm afraid to say, you can't
go and buy in a book somewhere
or go and buy a bottle of
entrepreneur juice and boots,
or something like that.
You're either born with it or not.
And it doesn't come out initially.
It is normally others
that observe your aptitude
and it is others that encourage you along.
So in my career,
I kind of always had
people that I respected
and where was my first respect?
Well, in my humble family,
it was to look up to an uncle of mine
who was the only one that had a business.
He had a small shop not
far from here, actually,
in Victoria, so he was
someone I looked up to.
And of course, it didn't take very long
that I passed him over,
and when I passed him over,
the next person I looked up to
was one of the guys that
I was buying stuff from.
Because he was the man, you know?
And then I passed him over, also.
And eventually got up the
ladder 'til you reach someone
by the name of Rupert
Murdoch, for example.
I haven't passed him over, yet, but.
And I never will, but
I mean, on that climb,
there were great names
like Lord Weinstock,
for example, from GEC.
Great people that I
admire for their skills
and all that stuff.
And that's the people you look up to.
That's the motivation that you get.
They have got there, and
they've done it somehow.
So I'm going to do the same.